deux personnes sont mortes 9 ont été
blessées dans une tragédie à me que vous
le savez on a maintenant l'identité lors
de du chauffage Steve gagnant 38 ans il
sera fera l'objet d'accusation on va
tout de suite aller retrouver Ken Moreau
à qui est un témoin qui a échappé de
justesse au chauffage qui a appelé
délibérément une dizaine de piétons
comme ça bonjour monsieur Moreau
oui moi ça va bien mais je présume que
vous avec ce que vous avez vécu il va
avoir beaucoup d'émotions
j'aimais peut-être commencer par le tout
début de ce qu'on comprenne comment vous
vous sentez ce matin qu'est-ce que vous
avez vu vous hier particulièrement de
cette de cette tragédie
en fait
j'ai tout vu là j'étais
juste devant les premières personnes qui
se sont fait frapper
j'ai
je marchais sur le trottoir et puis
j'ai entendu j'entendu un boom là
derrière moi j'ai juste eu le temps de
me retourner puis j'ai vu véhicule qui
frappait tout le monde puis
je dis je dirigeait directement sur moi
puis la personne qui était à côté de moi
j'ai juste le temps sauter pour mettre à
l'abri là puis
il y a fauché tout le monde tout le
monde qui était ce trottoir est passé au
fond vous avez été chanceux d'avoir un
abri quoi c'est un c'est un poteau si
vous êtes caché derrière quelque chose
[Musique]
je sais pas trop le c'est un gros
pour éviter le chauffeur et qui était
complètement sur le trottoir
[Musique]
il est vraiment fauché tout le monde là
police tu dis ce matin que c'était
intentionnelle on comprend pas les
motifs mais c'est intentionnel vous ça
devait pas faire de doute aussi été sur
le trottoir où vous l'avez bien vu
rouler sur le trottoir c'était dans une
accélération
il y a pas eu de freinage là il y a
fauché tout le monde à une vitesse là
c'était je dis là ça s'est tellement
passé vite là c'est pas quelqu'un qui
qui a battait un piéton qui qui s'est
arrêté là il faut aussi les personnes
derrière moi et puis il faut aussi les
personnes qui étaient à côté de moi un
avant de moi qui était plus loin sur le
trottoir
les gens ont pas eu le temps
le monsieur qui était juste en avant de
moi on se retournant en même temps les
deux puis le monsieur est figé
je pense que ce monsieur là il est
décédé
d'avoir la bonne direction de sauter
tout d'un coup à mettre mais c'est ça
qu'on se dit toujours comment je
réagirais si alors vous est-ce que vous
êtes-vous dans les êtes-vous un premier
répondant êtes-vous dans ce genre de
chose
quel est le réflexe à ce moment là une
fois que vous avez saisi qu'est-ce qui
se passe qu'est-ce que c'est vous vous
courrez en direction posée vous
avez-vous pu aider des gens qui étaient
là ou même tenté de rattraper
c'est instinctivement là
j'ai essayé de porter secours aux deux
personnes qui étaient couché à terre les
deux messieurs
puis j'ai vu que il y avait pas grand
signe de
ça bougeait pas trop là il y avait une
grosse merde ça a été instantané
après
quasiment des intégré là avec sa
grand-mère en dessous
puis pas longtemps après le chauffeur
est viré de bord je l'ai vu revenir sur
les lieux en sens inverse puis
j'écris à tout le monde c'est lui c'est
lui
puis lui et c'est sauvé le même j'ai
essayé de courir un peu après mais pour
prendre le numéro de plaque et tout mais
je pense c'est rendu directement poste
de police après ça j'ai été porté
secours à la petite fille sur laquelle
je m'en allais au préalablement au début
après avoir constaté les deux messieurs
allongés puis on a des gens on a détaché
la petite fille de la poussette il y a
une madame qui l'a pris dans ses bras le
petit garçon il était désorienté vu tous
ces fêtes frapper la maman de rallonge
au sol en dessous du du garde de garde
de corps
d'un commerce la garde de corps en métal
je crois que c'est même une garde de
corps là qui m'a sauvé la ville et quand
le véhicule a frappé dedans là ça fait
un énorme baume
monsieur Moreau c'est sûr qu'on vous
écoute vous avez vous êtes allé conduire
les enfants à l'école je pense
[Musique]
pour essayer de parler de ça
parce que bien des gens ils disent que
j'aurais fait puisqu'on fait dans ces
cas-là est-ce que est-ce qu'on vous a
approchez pour vous offrir de l'aide
parce que là vous en parlez ça évacue
mais un moment donné malheureusement
puis je suis pas sûr que je souhaite
mais vous allez vous retrouver seul avec
vos pensées et puis là on a besoin de
parler on a besoin de conseils est-ce
que est-ce que des gens qui vous
empêchent pour vous dire si vous parlez
Ken viennent nous voir on va on va on a
des solutions pour toi
la sortie du Québec me prend en charge
automatiquement là je connaissais un
policier sur les lieux
j'ai parlé avec eux là j'étais dans
l'auto patrouille à donner ma déposition
il m'a offert de me reconduire à
l'hôpital les gens de CLSC sont venus
directement sur les lieux de l'accident
pour offrir leur aide aux gens
je les remercie là j'ai pas pris live
mais
c'est apprécié c'est disponible monsieur
Moreau
que vous en avez besoin en tout cas si
on était là on vous serait tout je pense
collectivement dans nos bras pour vous
vous soutenir comme ça on vous remercie
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
décrire cette scène là c'est c'est
admirable ou réflexes en tout cas vous
avez des bons réflexes monsieur Moreau
dites-vous au moins ça vous vous voulez
merci beaucoup monsieur Margot au revoir
merci bonne journée à vous bonne journée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI